And I hereby declare that something actually.
And so with that declaration,
it's over for Labour here in pendulum.
They failed to win a single seat
after all their councils resigned and went independent.
But how much of this is down to the parties in decision over Gaza?
And if this is happening at local elections,
should Keir Starmer be worried about the general election?
We tried to speak to Labour Party members afterwards
and they told us they wouldn't be giving interviews.
I have to say, they disappeared pretty sharpish after the counts.
Now,
some are comparing it to what happened to Labour after the Iraq war.
It wasn't just here in Pendle.
The party suffered losses in areas like Burnley and Blackburn.
And in Oldham, they lost overall control of the town council.
Now, Oldham does have a particularly complicated local history.
The party had been seeing a loss of support there
before October the seventh.
But still, the loss came as a shock.
And some initial analysis suggested
in wards that have more than 10% of the population who are Muslim,
the party's share fell by 8%.
An Oldham, of course,
neighbours Rochdale, where George Galloway recently won a by election
by campaigning on the issue of Oldham.
I spoke to one councillor here who had resigned as a Labour councillor.
He won today as an independent.
Listen to what he told me
and what it says to you about the issue of Palestine.
Palestine free. Free Palestine. Free.
Free Palestine! This is not just for the people of pendulum.
This is for the people of Palestine.
This is for the two and a half million who are still under siege.
This. This victory is for them in particular.
This was the reason myself and my agent and my leader,
Counselor Yasir Akbal, we signed from the Labour Party in October,
and obviously the people have now spoken.
And as Councilor Ashraf also said to me,
it's not just Muslims, of course,
who care about the issue of Gaza.
Many people here raised it on the doorsteps.
That's what some conservative councillors said to me as well.
And today the party's campaign coordinator,
PAC McFadden, has done a round of interview,
the party acknowledges it has to listen to voters on this issue
and try and win back their trust.
Because the big question for the party is,
if this is what's happening in local elections,
how will it play out in the general election?